[Musique]
peut pas être immortel parce qu'elle est
morte
bah c'est qu'elle la place dans le
congèle on n'a qu'à la mettre là dedans
en attendant c'est quoi ça temps mais
c'est une météorite
tu fais quoi avec un vieux ni toi hein
quoi franchement je sais pas si je vais
tenir une semaine de plus avec vous tous
ici ça commence à faire beaucoup
[Musique]
bon alors c'est simple vous fixez le
point là bon là c'est un miroir je sais
c'est pas une vitre sans tain dans love
stories aller ça mais c'est pas la même
prod c'est pas les mêmes moyens mais ça
y est assez bien et puis vous lâchez
tout ce que vous avez sur le coeur un
bovidé madsack comme si vous étiez chez
le psy ou ou comme si vous parliez votre
communauté twitter
et puis vraiment à les y aller dit parce
que je trouve vraiment qu'on a une
ambiance de merde là et puis ça est un
bon moyen de régler tout ça un créatif
tu viens tu commences c'est débile son
truc je veux pas parler une vitre quand
même vous êtes sûrement déjà demandé
comment on pourrait améliorer français
pour qu'ils soient plus efficaces
histoire que l'on communique plus
facilement et avec mon ambiguïté et
comme on vit dans une époque formidable
avec l'outil informatique pour nous
assister avec une science qui n'a jamais
été aussi dynamique
on devrait théoriquement pouvoir pomper
nos langues afin qu'elles soient plus
optimales pour communiquer si seulement
c'était si simple
cette problématique elle est tout sauf
nouvelle le philosophe francis bacon
théorise déjà la langue universelle
optimale en 1605 en imaginant système
d'écriture où chaque symbole correspond
à un seul radical une seule notion un
seul concept afin que chacun puisse lire
et comprendre un texte sans en parler la
langue
alors évidemment c'est vain puisque
dissocier la langue de sa grammaire et
comme toutes les langues ne met pas les
mots dans mes morts par exemple a peu de
chances que tout le monde s'y retrouve
d'autres après lui se pencheront sur le
problème que ce soit la cnidh comenius
filkins tolstoï ou même des cartes déjà
au xviie siècle dernier résume bien
l'idée que les gens se font encore
aujourd'hui de l'optimalité de la langue
une langue optimale est international à
la grammaire saint pée que l'on peut
apprendre quelques heures
de posséder ni exception ni irrégularité
ces principes sont à la base des langues
construites les plus connus comme le
veut la pub qui fut le premier a
rencontré un succès international et
l'espéranto ensuite qui le remplaça mais
entre 1880 et la seconde guerre mondiale
ce sont plus de 200 langues répondant à
ces critères qui seront créés la plupart
d'entre elles par des européens
le lexique optimale semblent à leur
tente pour beaucoup du côté des racines
européennes plutôt que d'améliorer une
langue déjà existantes on pourrait donc
créer une langue de toutes pièces qui
répondent à ces critères d'optimalité
afin de transmettre le plus rapidement
possible des informations entre êtres
humains mais aussi à destination d'une
machine ou d'un ordinateur ou pour
reprendre les arguments de beaucoup de
créateurs de ces langues apporter la
paix dans le monde
ah ouais autant être ambitieux un petit
peu et donc tous d'ambition quand même
je sais pas comment ils font pour
s'assumer en tant qu'individu non mais
un créatif il un de ces melons et c'est
incroyable il fait des grands discours
inspirant à la cool et tout ça à machin
mais en fait tout le monde sait que
c'est un fait marc florence par exemple
est ce qu'elle entreprendrait elle-même
de sortir les poubelles ou faire la
vaisselle par exemple ce qu'elle
bousculeraient le planning est ce
qu'elles feraient preuve d'initiative
manon parce que pour elle il ya que les
règles les règles les règles les règles
alors pour moi les règles c'est fait
pour être bousculées caen pour être
affranchis et justement la bonté par
exemple avec ce truc de confessionnal
bas ça j'aime bien à toi c'est
disruptive c'est bien oui savent pas ce
qui les attend mais ça promet vêtements
à moi ça va à part quelques problèmes
sauf que on communique pas trop mal
la première langue construite à visée
l'optimalité certainement le lot glane
conçu en 1955 par james cook brown
puisqu'elle visait un but scientifique
dans la recherche linguistique le log
line dont le nom est composé de logic et
language visé plusieurs put être
purement basée sur la logique tout
d'abord mais également être neutre
culturellement être la plus minimaliste
grammaticalement pour être facilement
apprise être la plus élaborée possible
pour néanmoins permettre des
raisonnements complexes et finalement
être dénué d'ambiguïté
elle visait alors invalidé l'hypothèse
sapir world dans sa version forte selon
laquelle la langue structure notre
pensée il suffirait de voir si une
langue purement basée sur la logique
pourrait amener ses locuteurs à penser
plus logiquement le lot glanant le
principe rappelle le langage
mathématiques et logiques ont tenté de
créer fritsch le seul écart n'a un
énoncé simple et transformé en en néon
c'est logique prenons par exemple la
phrase tous les chiens sont bleus on
pourra noter ainsi
tout x ou x est un chien x et bleu loeb
l'alsacien de cette notation
mathématiques et traduit cette annonce
est ainsi un akouda kangoo dablam houda
équivaut à l'inconnu que l'on définit
kangoo et blanot aux arguments à savoir
chiens et bleu à à tout coup à celui ci
ou à 6 alors l'histoire du log l'un
d'eux finira mal james cobra on espère
de l'argent de son université pour sa
création mais celle ci eut reçu l'homme
qui est alors insulté dans son honneur
veut conserver un contrôle strict sur le
log lane afin notamment d'en exploiter
d'éventuels droits d'auteur bien que
cela puisse sembler incroyable bran
considérait avoir un droit de propriété
sur le lexique c'est à dire sur chaque
module og
attendez on peut déposer une langue et
demandé du droit d'auteur au bon bah
ouais alors est-ce qu'on peut déposer
des langues est ce qu'on peut copyright
et des mots est ce qu'on peut propriété
intellectuelle en tout ca machin tu as
bien les trucs à dire là dessus
non mais tu te renseignes et puis tu
l'as en fait c'est pas parce que tu fais
du droit que tu connais tous enfin tu
peux pas être spécialiste de la question
sur toutes les toutes les choses qui
existent d'accord donc tu vas pas me
répondre
tu vas pas avoir un podologue carter un
problème de dans la match beira du
travail mais je connais un podologue la
piste souple et très honorable et qui
peut de faire je pense une ou deux
coureurs peut-être un problème de
branques ça j'ai bien compris
bon bah j'ai fait l'accolade de monter
sur la communication optimale
bon je vais pas vous cacher on n'était
pas vraiment très intéressant façon
j'aime pas bosser avec lui je trouve
vraiment discourtois et rustique nord
est monté ça va j'ai pas trop de
problèmes
je limite mes interactions inclus par
contre moi monté je les aime beaucoup il
a été d'une grande aide pour moi après
la mort de charles ix il en parlait
beaucoup avec des mots quitté les siens
c'est sûr mais ça partait du coeur j'en
suis persuadé depuis que la cousine de
valentine est morte on paye quand même
vingt balles de moins d'électricité
j'ai envie de dire un mal pour un bien
quoi qu'il en soit à james coburn prend
un peu le melon il explique dans sa g et
révisé du lot glane de 1989 que sa
langue est un médicament efficace face à
la maladie de la pensée limité
un moyen d'éveiller l'humanité qu'elle
devrait enseigner aux enfants du monde
entier un peu prétentieux le bonhomme un
peu à ce moment là une partie de
l'équipe de james cours brand l'a déjà
lâché dans son délire et s'est retiré du
projet logan en 1987 ces séparatistes
log la liste ont créé une autre langue
visant les mêmes buts que cette dernière
a logique avant tout la neutralité
culturel la non d'ambiguïté des énoncés
et surtout pas d'histoire de droit
d'auteur ni de délire mégalomane c'est
le lunch ban qui ne tarde pas à dépasser
le lot glanant terme de contributeurs et
d'impact mais est ce que c'est si
optimale que ça finalement
eh bien pas du tout parce que si on peut
analyser le launchpad comme un langage
de programmation informatique il est en
réalité très peu pratique pour
communiquer les constructions même et
énoncer les plus élémentaires sont très
lourdes
le critère de nos ambiguïtés est un
handicap puisque autre chose c'est bien
beau d'avoir plein de façons différentes
de dire et où en fonction du sens exact
que l'on veut faire passer
et cette précision et dans un contexte
conversation quotidien très superflu le
temps nécessaire que l'on met à former
une phrase correcte on est sûr que le
sens correspondent exactement notre
pensée est beaucoup trop long et le
temps nécessaire pour comprendre une
phrase l'est tout autant
surtout que la langue relève au
quotidien d'un acte essentiellement
spontanée on n'est pas sorti du bois si
on doit mettre deux minutes pour
réfléchir à chacune de ses phrases
bon ok parler de manière non ambiguë et
culturellement neutre est un horizon
inatteignable qui semble complexifier la
communication plutôt que la rendre
optimale pour nous humains peut-être
tout simplement parce que nos langues
évoluent dans un contexte social et
culturel qui est bien plus qu il ne
dessert et qui apporte à nos langues
naturelles les informations
indispensables à l'oral parce que le
contexte est centrale pouvait dire j'ai
froid pour faire comprendre j'ai besoin
que tu ferme la fenêtre s'il te plaît
celle qui est derrière toi
geffroy véhicule alors beaucoup plus
d'informations que la simple idée que
vous ayez froid et chercher à transposer
cet énoncé hors de tout contexte nous
fait perdre en réalité beaucoup
d'informations tu as bien un truc tu
dois dire sur le contexte avec ses
pommes à la cobla
dix ans c'est rien pas vraiment grand
chose non plus en fait la base où
quelques trucs le contexte oui le
contexte est important ce que suivant le
lieu on va communiquer ou même la
période de l'est tu as su communiquer à
noël ce communiqué je sais pas moi dans
une école dans la rue et c'est déjà tout
ça il ya une prise de conscience et un
contexte qui fait que ben le message on
va être interprété différemment
et voilà elle à la cible aussi et tous
ses références ça va influencer aussi à
la manière dont on va s'adresse à lui
les images qu'on va lui présenter ce
genre de choses donc voilà et moi j'ai
un exemple en fait de marque confirmé
c'est juste ou pas mais pour moi de mark
a fait un peu de la communication
optimale je trouve que c'est je pense tu
vois les la bière gordon non non c'est
une bière qui a fait assez fort assez
chargé et du coup les se positionne pas
mal là dessus toi sur le fait c'est un
truc de bonhomme tu prend en compte tout
ce contexte là donc
passé de la marque sachant qu'elle a
déjà une certaine réputation qui est
déjà bien assise autour du fait qu'elle
est forte
le fait qu'elles ciblent ces personnes
là qu'elle s'intéresse qu'à cela donc on
doit dire contre qu'on s'adresse à des
bonhommes tu vois eh ben ça fait qu'ils
ont fait une campagne en fait tout c'est
juste la canette de bière sur des fonds
très simple où il est écrit rien à
prouver et au final en faisant ça c'est
intéressant parce que du coup tu
communiques quelque chose tu communiques
plein de choses sera un communiqué en
fait parce que tout est content voilà
c'est tout et les contacts des
contingents de ce qu'il veut voilà ce
qu'il veut la marque ne dirai à même
temps il ya un côté prétentieux un peu
cool genre la marque elle pèse elle est
là elle est c'est un truc de bonhomme et
où il ya rien à prouver ya rien à dire
pas de slogan de trucs à ferrero que ce
soit non c'est le produit en lui-même
comme ça sa réputation la personne à qui
elle s'adresse et tous créés autour de
ce à quoi ça raconte un truc sans rien
dire et bien pour un mec rien à dire
tant avec des trucs à dire c'est un vrai
parce que je n'ai pas fait de petites
présage donc j'avais la pression d'avoir
travaillé judéo pas mal pas mal non mais
tu m'as tu m'as presque intéressés une
petite note
non non pour autant ne jetons pas le
bébé avec l'eau du bain
ces chasses et l'ambiguïté n'est pas un
bon plan il n'empêche qu'on peut
continuer à chasser l'irrégularité
pourquoi avoir autant de radicaux verbe
savoir par exemple savoir je sais qu'ils
sachent et su je saurai que nous succion
peut légitimement imaginer que plus de
régularité ça fait moins de modèles à
assimiler suffit de voir la difficulté
que c'est pour nous d'apprendre le latin
avec toutes ses déclinaisons
pareil pour l'allemand ou pour le russe
alors que l'anglais ou il ya ni masculin
ni féminin ni déclinaison c'est quand
même vachement plus simple quand même
marché pas c'est en tout cas quelque
chose qu'on entend beaucoup
si on suit cette logique une langue
comme le mandarin relativement
régulières et des nuits de déclinaisons
serait plus optimale peu plus que mal
dispose de mort relativement court
beaucoup de termes composé d'une seule
syllabe la vitesse de transmission de
l'information doit être d'autant plus
rapide alors allons-nous tous devoir
apprendre à parler comme les chinois
rassurez vous ce n'est pas le cas une
étude conduite par des chercheurs du
cnrs il ya quelques mois a montré que
peu importe la langue que vous parlez
communiqué la même quantité
d'informations par seconde estimée
environ
39 buts plus ou moins cinq dit alors
pour le calcul me demandez pas comment
ils ont fait vous irez directement voir
l'étude en question qui est en
description c'est effectivement le
mandarin dispose de mots plus court que
l'espagnol par exemple si donc chaque
syllabe est en moyenne vectrices une
plus grande quantité d'informations
le débit de parole d'un locuteur du
mandarin est plus faible que celui d'un
locuteur de l'espagnol plus une langue
véhicule d'information par syllabe moins
on la parle vite donc comme s'il
existait une limite technique à nos
langues
en tout cas ça fait vraiment du bien de
pouvoir parler sans plomber l'ambiance
je sais que c'est parfois un peu lourd
de discuter avec les autres du décès de
ma cousine ou de cette sordide histoire
de météorites qui a conduit un homme à
l'hôpital
ici je peux vraiment aborder les choses
bon après je suis pas sûr que ça dérange
les autres mais hamelin l'antenne ces
malaises incarné à ben si on votait pour
éliminer des candidats comme à la belle
époque de la télé-réalité sur la chaîne
nationale est bas et peut-être que
valentine aurait vécu un coup dur
j'adore valentino mais faut vraiment
qu'elle arrête de faire des blagues sur
sa famille surtout quand ils sont
décédés et surtout quand ils sont
dissimulés illégalement en couche tard
de maisons salette taffaleau deuil mais
moi j'arrive pas à oublier kiabi sous
sachet de frites et vous cher public
vous voteriez pour éliminer qui est bien
laisser un commentaire que je n'irai pas
quand on conceptualise l'optimalité chez
nous autres européens allaient focaliser
sur la morphologie c'est à dire sur la
forme des mots en revanche elle ne
concerne jamais ou rarement la syntaxe
est à dire l'ordre des mots ni la
phonologie c'est à dire les sons qui
utilise une langue
alors certes l'anglais est une langue
considéré comme facile grammaticalement
c'est à dire sur sa morphologie quoique
on pourrait débattre ce point précis et
c'est une langue à la syntaxe rigide
c'est à dire à l'ordre des mots très
très rigide c'est en réalité tout à fait
logique
sanka grammatico c'est à dire sans
déclinaison des mots comme en latin en
allemand ou en russe
l'information grammaticales n'est pas
portée sur les mots mais sur la phrase
l'ordre des mots notamment en allemand
si on peut indifféremment dire damon et
10 francs où 10 francs aux idées man
sont que le sens global de change car
les déclinaisons identifie qui fait ou
qui subit l'action ce n'est absolument
pas possible en français ni en anglais
car en l'absence de cas grammatico en
l'absence de déclinaisons c'est l'ordre
des mots qui détermine qui subit qui
fait l'action l'homme voit la femme ou
la femme voit l'homme conduisent à des
résultats très différents des rives
à opposer même comme vous parlez
français cela vous paraît naturel et
certainement logique
sachez cependant que cet ordre des mots
n'est pas majoritaire dans le monde cet
ordre sujet verbe objet est présent dans
42 % des langues 45% d'entre elles
préfèrent en revanche l'ordre sujet
objet verbe qui la disposition la plus
courante l'on trouve en japonais en
basque en hindi en coréen par exemple
suivre l'ordre sujet verbe objets que
l'on trouvera en français ou en anglais
ce n'est pas naturel ni optimale et
c'est même une sacrée contraintes
lorsque l'on parle une langue à
l'origine qui propose à l'ordre des mots
beaucoup plus libre on pourrait aussi
aller voir du côté de la phonologie
l'anglais encore une fois possède en
réalité une phonologie très complexe
avec douze voiliers l'aider diphtongues
c'est à dire des combinaisons de deux
voyelles là aussi assez nombreuses
on a de nombreuses consonnes distinguer
qui ne le sont pas dans plein de langues
comme leurs oeufs et le lait qui sont
confondus en mandarin ou en japonais
on pourrait aussi parler de
l'accentuation des mots qui en anglais
et bien souvent imprévisible et
absolument pas régulière bien qu'elle
soit parfois distinctive le mot hymne
porte cette annonce il est accentué sur
la première syllabe
mais un verbe s'il est accentuée sur la
seconde syllabes et lorsque la syllabe
d'un mot en anglais et inaction tuer le
timbre de la voyelle change souvent de
sorte à obtenir un chauffard c'est à
dire une voyelle neutre l'optimalité
donc telle qu'on la perçoit est telle qu
on la définit historiquement en europe
et très ethnocentrée autant plus que
nous parlons en europe des langues qui
emprunte des chemins évolutif similaire
ayant pour origine même langue le proto
à d'européens qui étaient parlées dans
les steppes ukrainienne il y a six ou
huit mille ans mais revenons sur les
régularités comment justifier son
existence n'est ce pas superflu quoi
qu'il arrive
si vous avez suivi ce que j'ai dit
l'irrégularité ne doit jamais être perçu
comme uniquement porté sur la
morphologie sur la forme des mots il est
parfois plus efficaces de justement
troqué la régularité d'un modèle
morphologiques pour faciliter la
prononciation d'un mot par exemple il
existe même en phonétique une loi
appelée la loi du relâchement
articulatoires tendance de fond de
certaines évolutions est à l'origine de
plusieurs mutations phonétique courante
parce que vous ne vous en rendez pas
compte mais les langues évoluent le
français y compris
alors certes c'est évolue lentement si
bien que vous ne vous en rendez pas
compte la plupart du temps mais ça
évolue quand même et lorsque langue
évolue elle se met déjà en quête de
l'optimalité on invente des mots dont on
a besoin tout en éliminant ce qui
n'existe plus dans l' usage on emprunte
ce qui nous manque
est ce une forme irrégulière et trop peu
utilisée elle est alors abandonné ou
modifiées pour entrer dans un modèle
plus courant est plus simple un mot
irrégulier se maintient en revanche très
bien s'il est très utilisé comme le
verbe être et ses formes conjuguées part
les irrégularités d'aujourd'hui doivent
être perçus comme des évolutions passées
de la langue ou des vestiges des
systèmes anciens
si le verbe être et aussi régulier
lorsque l'on conjugue au présent c'est
parce que chaque forme a subi une
évolution phonologique à travers les
siècles qui ont conduit à ce résultat de
cette pression à l'évolution
phonologique était bien plus forte que
la pression du maintien de la régularité
et faut avouer qu'elles sont bien
pratiques
de même la forme populaire chu où je
suis contre actions de jeu et suit est
hautement irrégulière au regard des
autres est à la fois très courte bien
comprise et largement identifiables
comme le son jeu et se sont très proches
dans la bouche est difficile à prononcer
l'un après l'autre la forme chu et plus
optimale le sont chez eux ayant le même
point le même mode d'articulation que le
son jeu mais dévoisé c'est à dire sans
l'intervention des cordes vocales comme
le sont par ailleurs l'irrégularité et
parfois l'étape nécessaire entre deux
systèmes qui eux sont tout à fait
régulier par exemple le mot by faits
sont plurielles ambaud historiquement et
c'est le cas encore dans le secteur de
l'immobilier le mob aille dans le sens
histoire rumeurs ragots ayant fait
surface ces dernières années fait quant
à lui son pluriel de manière régulière
un bail d by tu connais les balles à
première vue on pourrait percevoir ici
une irrégularité un défaut d'optimalité
mais faut plutôt le voir ainsi le
pluriel en eau des moments à l'oua est
en train de disparaître
beaucoup de mots empruntés au cours des
derniers siècles forme d'ailleurs leur
pluriel régulièrement comme carnaval ou
chacal bail en tant que mots nouveaux et
régulier se distingue du mot bail en
tant qu'ancien mauvais ce t-shirt
système qui aura bientôt cesser
d'exister
c'est une évolution en cours qui suit
son cours l'évolution n'aura pas me
laisse pantoise un j'avoue je mens
c'était pareil que les anciens
locataires
après ça va ma situation moi elle est
confortable avec ils sont vachement -
ballack moi je me demande bien comment
ça va finir
mais comment peut-on prédire une
évolution dans la langue d'ailleurs on
ne peut jamais avec certitude mais on
peut observer que s'il restera peut-être
toujours des archaïsmes les langues
évoluent en suivant une tendance de fond
c'est ce qu'on appelle le cycle de
grammaticales isation est par définition
ce cycle est un modèle très lent et très
généraliste qui s'applique plus ou moins
en fonction des cas que l'on étudie ce
cycle on peut le schématiser ainsi
prenons une langue qui serait constitué
de paradigme organisé bien réguliers
bien optimale finalement selon les
penseurs cité au début de cet épisode
avec le temps si ce n'est pas déjà le
cas les à fixes comme les prépositions
se colleraient au monde on verrait alors
apparaître ce qu'on appelle des cas
grammatico c'est à dire ce qu'on appelle
couramment des déclinaisons appelons
cela le stade 1
avec le temps les mutations politiques
comme la loi du relâchement
articulatoires dont on a déjà parlé
pourrait alléger la difficulté de
prononciation de certaines formes
pourrait réduire la taille des mots et
c'est sans parler des diverses mutations
qui de toute façon apparaissent avec le
temps de fêtes des irrégularités
apparaissent dans les paradigmes
c'est à dire dans les modèles de
déclinaisons le système régulier de
biens irrégulier les modèles deviennent
parfois opaques
le temps passant encore les déclinaisons
finirait par disparaître tout comme les
flexions et marc de conjugaison aussi
les marques de plurielles aussi c'est le
stade 3 le stade iv c
lorsqu'apparaissent des constructions
syntaxique pour remplacer les
déclinaisons disparu la construction de
la phrase porte désormais l'information
grammaticales nécessaires à la
compréhension d'un énoncé
on voit alors des nouveaux temps
apparaître par exemple construit avec
les auxiliaires les déterminants
devienne obligatoire car il sert
désormais à indiquer le jean ou le
nombre du mot qu'il détermine au stade 5
toutes ces nouvelles structures se
rigidifie et se fige puis au stade 6 on
analyse ses déterminants ou ses
propositions comme des à fixe c'est à
dire comme des marques directement lié
aux mots nous sommes en réalité
retourner aux premiers stades
le français actuellement et dans le
stade iv le proto gallo roman parlé
durant le début du moyen-âge en france
en était au stade 3 le latin au stade 2
le proto 1 européen probablement au
stade ce qui nous paraît optimale ce sur
quoi ont beaucoup écrit les philosophes
cours des derniers siècles
si on regarde bien c'est ce vers quoi on
tend actuellement le stade 5 ou le stade
6 des structures régulière un ordre des
mots plus que jamais déterminant bref
l'optimalité et ce vers quoi la langue
temps d'elle-même et avec l'inertie qui
est la sienne
finalement chercher la langue la plus
optimale qui soit une basse et une
entreprise qui semble vaine de langue
actuelle aussi imparfaite soit elle
cherche en permanence à s'adapter à
coller la société à laquelle on vit il
s'appuie pour cela sur le contexte donc
est à la fois extérieure à nous mais
aussi intérieure c'est à dire tributaire
de notre biologie de langues sont aussi
ce qu'elles sont car notre corps est ce
qu'il est et nos organes sont ce qu'ils
sont nous avons vu précédemment que
décontextualisés une langue n'est pas
efficace du tout s'affranchir de notre
culture de notre société de notre corps
et évite l ambiguïté peut sembler plus
universel et donc moins susceptible de
créer des problèmes de compréhension
mais en tendant vers un fonctionnement
plus logique au sens informatique ou
mathématique du terme nous extrayons la
langue de son fonctionnement habituel et
nous créons finalement bien plus de
problèmes de communication que l'on en
est vite
cela peut sembler contre intuitif mais
exploité le contexte est certainement
plus optimale la langue est un produit
social il ne faut jamais l'oublier
idem pour les régularités ans nous
obstinons à ne voir que celles qui
portent sur la morphologie en nous
de voir les autres en quoi elles peuvent
en réalité être la conséquence de
simplification conduisant à plus de
petits mâles ite tel mot est peut-être
irrégulier en forme et peut-être que
cette irrégularité est venu corriger une
difficulté à le prononcer en latin par
exemple le suffixe alice se transforme
en harris après intel pour éviter la
prononciation de deux ailes de suite
singh glycines glaris mais pour s
floralys en france est singulier et
pluriel n'ont pas du tout la même
terminaison mais sont originellement
construite sur le même modèle avec le
même suffixe latin qui a été altéré pour
faciliter la prononciation d'ailleurs
une langue comme l'espéranto fait au
début du 20e siècle est basé sur la
régularité stricte expérimente
aujourd'hui après un siècle d'existence
quelques évolutions naturelles qui
viennent mettre à mal sa régularité
parfaite
certains mots en changer de
prononciation en cours de route plus
facile à prononcer comme rémy gnocchis
existe aussi sous la forme qu'emilio
certaines formes comme celle du verbe
être sont régulièrement abrégé comme
estas en strass et la syntaxe
théoriquement libre et dans les faits de
plus en plus rigides mais je trouve à
titre personnel qu'on se prend trop la
tête
sur ces questions d'optimalité car le
français par exemple est tout à fait
équipé pour être à la fois très précis
dans certains cas et beaucoup moins
quand cela n'est pas tir constance c'est
ce qu'on appelle les jargons en fait
chaque milieu qui nécessitent d'être
précis dans son domaine en fait usage
c'est souvent des termes l'on est pas
ambiguë du tout d'ailleurs ils ne sont
souvent pas le dictionnaire que vous
avez dans votre bibliothèque
il risquerait sinon de tripler de volume
imaginez s'il fallait tous les maîtriser
tous les jargons de tous les milieux ah
bah on pourrait parler très précisément
entre nous c'est sûr mais dans les faits
on n'utiliserait jamais la majeure
partie des mots mémoriser et cela serait
de l'espace inutilement occupé à serait
loin d'être optimales alors peut-être
que le mot hystéro cinétique est super
pratique en linguistique historique pour
l'étude de la reconstruction du proto
européen et qu'il m'a été utile pour moi
à l'université pour voulait certainement
superflu un accent hystéro cinétique
c'est un accent passe du suffixe à la
terminaison quand il est décliné dans
les cafés bhl comme dans le mot terme
alors vous n'êtes pas super avancé
faudrait définir en linguistique à quoi
correspond un suffixe une terminaison un
café est blé tous les symboles utilisés
dans le bois fiche à l'écran et la
flemme un peu du coup vraiment
l'optimalité c'est donc certainement à
la situation actuelle
chaque milieu maîtrise son jargon et
même si cela concerne une minorité celle
qui en a besoin et part ça suffit
lorsque le plus grand nombre doit y
avoir accès la vulgarisation est là pour
nous faire comprendre rendre accessibles
ces phrases jargonner et c'est bien
comme ça voilà si cet épisode vous a plu
vous pouvez laqué commenté partagez vous
abonner faire péter le compteur de vue
je suis remonté la vidéo en tendance et
surtout nous rejoindre sur discorde ce
soir où d'autres jours pour notamment
débriefer de tout cela j'ai des rochers
là vos interventions dans le
confessionnal attend ont été filmés
attend quoi
mais ça se fait pas de film et jean leur
insu valentine mollo parce que c'est pas
comme ça que tu vas convaincre les gens
de garder un
et puis florent ce serais toi je la
ramènerai pas trop un bus que tu
balances sur moi oui vous étiez filmique
qui ce que vous aviez cru mais regardez
pas ce que ça devrait vous intéresser
quand même bon moment j'ai cru que
florence à les comprendre mais ils sont
tous tombés en panne au de confondre un
oeuf d'agonie une météorite géante name
valentine est tombé dans le panneau
coincé comment ils ont pu gober ça non
mais je peux tout expliqué attend quoi
un oeuf de yoni les trucs on se met dans
la tulipe
mais tu foutais quoi avec ça tu m'as
laissé faire un épisode là dessus on l'a
vendu à un mec et maintenant il est à
l'hôpital mais non mais cesser ses
attaques au sinn charles est de voir
celle qu'évoque je crois pas que c'est
plus grave ça que s'occuper de ça comme
ça moi à la base je voulais juste la
couvrir pour son oeuvre de machin jeudi
en fait alors faites vous reprocher
d'être gentil voilà c'est au mont dieu
il est gentil je suis vraiment désolé
désolé d'avoir voulu être fidèle non
mais c'est quoi cette défense t'as pas
honte quand même lâché tous les stresser
un bon coup qu'on puisse passer à autre
chose
[Musique]
oui c'est qui c'est moi c'est moi
actuellement depuis tous riches des prix
twitch qui vous dit que vous pouvez
venir pour en parler pour parler de ce
sujet c'est pas beau c'est pas
magnifique ça donc venez venez
finalement venez en parler dans le tchat
venez discuter de tout ça livrer vos
réflexions poussées intense et c'est
déjà pas mal
n'est ce pas